pc gamers had one hell of a year in 2021
and while pc gaming may share many a hit
game with its console brethren for this
list of the best pc games of 2021 we're
looking at the games that could only be
found on that platform
with one exception one rules we didn't
see any rules did we charlie wrong sir
wrong that means no death loop and its
masterful approach to groundhog day gun
play no resident evil village and it's
incredibly tall ladies my decision is
final it will be nowhere for it and no
halo infinite the missions change
they always do
without further ado here are gamespot's
best pc exclusive games from 2021
a mouse and keyboard are generally the
go-to tools for playing any game on pc
but before your eyes tosses that
hardware aside
and instead gives full control over its
narrative
to your eyeballs
an innovative approach to storytelling
that focus on full ocular control isn't
just a gimmick but a genuinely immersive
method for experiencing a story about
life death and seeing the impact that
your character had on the people around
them i'm just
really behind right now
why don't you take photos in the
backyard it may not be interesting at
first but
if you keep going back out there every
day you'll be surprised by how much it
changes there's more to before your eyes
than just an innovative control scheme
though as the immersive story and
melancholic themes deliver one of the
most distinct gameplay experiences of
2021
one that will stick with you long after
the end credits have rolled
you know my father once told me when i
was about your age
the only way to fight against time
is to create a work of genius
which might live on after you're gone
in gamespot's before your eyes review
andrew king gives it an 8 out of 10
writing before your eyes understands
that experiencing our lives or storing
memories which become precious is often
tied to what we see the people and the
paths stretching out before us instead
of feeling like a gimmick before your
eyes feels refreshingly natural
we'll have to keep our eyes on that
[Music]
day really slipped away didn't it
one of the biggest success stories of
the year valheim's spin on a well-worn
formula of scavenging exploration and
attempting to improve your quality of
life still managed to feel incredibly
fresh this year it's the small details
that matter and for a game built by an
absolutely tiny studio valheim's focus
on improving the core of the survival
crafting genre is nothing short of
awe-inspiring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a game that's both a nail-biting
odyssey into dangerous territory that
could derail all of your progress and a
scenic moment of pure calm thanks to its
deliberate pixelated art direction
tension and catharsis in a single
package in gamespot's feature richard
wakeling wrote valheim is more fleshed
out than many finished games and it's
going to be exciting to see how it
evolves over the next year as systems
are improved and more content is added
the world of valheim is already a
wonderful one to inhabit and i can't
wait to see where it goes from here
[Music]
wilder myth looks like the end result of
what would happen if you smashed a
turn-based tactical rpg into a
children's bedtime storybook oh my
journal my drawings these pages are old
mom well careful
this is all from your hero days huh and
before but that's just too brief of a
description of one of the best pc games
of 2021. a game about the power of
stories wildemoth put an impressive
amount of narrative control into the
hands of its players this year tasking
them with creating a team of adventurers
who could go out and save the day from
all manner of assorted monsters while it
sounds like a stock standard rpg at
first wildemoth builds on that
foundation by adding incredible value to
every action you take within its
tabletop world
you can always come with me show me how
things are done
i know you say that but
well
where'd my old sword get to
[Music]
inscriptions eerie card battles rely on
a unique tug-of-war system to declare a
winner in every match and every time the
scales tip in either direction there's a
good chance you'll be sweating bullets
as you watch the momentum constantly
shift especially when you're sharing a
table with a nightmarish creature that
attacks your hand with cards that can
create a perilous tipping point in their
favor
[Music]
riveting and unnerving inscriptions
combination of classic deck building fun
and dark web urban legends combine to
form a unique slice of entertainment
it's also a game with some unexpected
twists and turns so if you haven't yet
played it do your best to avoid finding
out any more before diving in in
gamespot's review david wild goose gave
it an 8 out of 10 writing not only is
the core card game at its best but it's
also where those mechanics are best
served by the richly atmospheric
trappings surrounding them
what is loop hero exactly there are many
stories in our past
[Music]
it's a game that can't easily be slotted
into any single genre as this wild ride
of fantasy and peril incorporates
strategy deck building and role-playing
mechanics into a package of old-school
visuals and auto-playing charm loop hero
is a game about being caught in an
endless loop always bringing you back to
square one but making certain that
you're in a better position than when
you started on your latest cyclic
journey through dark fantasy roguelike
danger beneath its vintage visuals lie
an incredibly deep and complex game one
with addictive properties that'll hook
you in for the long run dead simple to
get into it's amazing how much fun a
hands-off gaming experience can be when
it's crafted with immaculate precision
and care loop hero is the sole game on
this list currently available on another
platform but its mouse-centric control
scheme makes it a game best played on pc
in gamespot's review alessandro barbossa
wrote the thrill of learning in loop
hero is the driving force of its
procedural gameplay with each small
discovery and minute change in approach
producing outcomes you might not have
imagined its opening hours are a
punishing hurdle to overcome but once
you've found the rhythm of loop hero you
won't want to break from its beat
[Music]
[Music]
so there you have it gamespot's top 5 pc
exclusives of 2021 and one small cheat
we'll be revealing our top 5 xbox switch
and playstation games as well so make
sure you hit that subscribe button so
you can catch up on the best games of
the year speaking of we also have a big
old deep dive into why death loop is our
game of the year thanks for watching
[Music]